you
[Music]
I think it's that a healthy diets have
small amounts of me there's you can be a
vegetarian and be perfectly healthy and
vegetarians in general or healthier than
people who eat a lot of meat but there
are advantages to eating small amounts
of meat there are no they're not
necessary advantages but they're there
and certainly in developing countries
where kids don't have enough food a
little meat thrown in makes a big
nutritional difference in the United
States where there's plenty of food
around I don't think it makes very much
difference the only thing that
vegetarians need to worry about is
eating a variety of food and getting
enough calories which is not very hard
to do I don't see vegetarian diets as
being an issue in any way whatsoever as
long as there's some animal food in the
diet like eggs or fish or dairy products
or something like that
the minute you move from that into vegan
diets you raise questions about one
vitamin and that's vitamin b12 because
that only comes from products of animal
origin or bacterially fermented foods so
you have to make sure that you've got a
source of vitamin b12 in your diet and
that you're eating a variety of foods
but other than that I just don't see it
as an issue at all except for kids for
small children and sometimes hard for
children to get enough calories unless
they're getting enough fat in with the
vegan diets that they're getting but
parents vegan parents know how to deal
with that most of them and do a pretty
good job and the kids are healthy it's
fine I said I kind of see all that as a
non-issue and I'm surprised and the
passion about it on both sides I still
hear from people about how dangerous
vegetarian diets are which seems kind of
silly and on the other hand I hear from
vegetarians and vegans about how
terrible it is to eat meat and I don't
buy either one of those
yeah the issue of meat-eating and the
environment is a very important one
particularly industrially industrially
raised meat in confined animal feeding
operations where you have large number
of animals in a very small area and
there's the whole question of first of
all what happens to their waste because
a pig farm can easily produce the amount
of waste that a city of 20,000 people
would produce in a day and yet it's not
treated no human population of 20,000
would be allowed to produce waste that
wasn't treated to destroy pathogenic
bacteria and yet we have laws that allow
these places to pollute the environment
with animal waste I think that's huge
problem and you go to a place that's
near a pig farm and you know about that
pig farm miles away you can smell it
that's something that we need to do
something about and I don't think that
CAFO should be allowed to leave their
waste untreated
n'yar there are other issues that have
to do with greenhouse gases and the fact
that so much of our grain corn soybeans
and corn and soybeans particularly is
grown expressly to feed animals if we
didn't have if we didn't need so much
meat then we wouldn't need to grow all
that food to feed animals and that would
also have great benefits for the
environment so I guess where I stand on
this is if you do eat meat then just
don't eat so much of it
[Music]